okay I'm back uh I see green I see the
green square I don't know if people can
see this green square people see the
green square there this right there it
should be better and no I'm not in a
hotel I've had a friend's place who's
supposed to have very good internet so I
just lowered the bit rates hopefully
it's better hotels in London are not
really known for superior Wi-Fi
well it's gonna be superior to the Wi-Fi
I have back home hopefully a whole oats
of people in the chat thanks for
watching Nathan and Belgium novice and
hero okay
good crowd I'm not a hostess imal let's
do 5 plus 5 plus 15 create
these people Minh Truong 2110 hello
hello - Annika hello Marie kya roll okay
on Achatz the first one to join will
accept him if I can click
except all these people this is going to
be
is gonna be a big sign one two three
four five six I'm not gonna accept this
guy because his rating is high I already
have 120 100 the one guy whom not
accepting I'm sorry but if you want to
play me send me a challenge uh uh and
then I will likely accept challenges
after this
if Nathan wants to play you can send me
a challenge too but I'm gonna start the
Simon I'm doing well hello to more
people it's just the same people saying
hi and I'm gonna play the lunge in every
game because I'm actually in London it's
a great city perhaps an even greater
opening c5 what is this let's take the
oh I didn't want to play d5 but that's
not a bad now slip Nathan with the bits
London's good while the people playing
anti London's which is a bit unfortunate
güven kurtz hello hello excise sparks
okay so we have a few true London's here
one mundane versus King's Indian one
copycat London f5 I used to play this
sign is black what's up some move here
do I play me for immediately Oh g4 is a
move
I'm trying to remember
three could be a move
much time and it's not necessary
okay I mean look like h4 because the
only way for back to develop is to play
this g6 move and I'll try not to flag h5
okay that makes me happy
let's play Knight h3 weird opening night
f6 interesting mean b3
uptime is my pot not working
and I thought my pod is having errors
I'm sorry about that
I've only been live for about like three
minutes so if you just joined your your
very early uh Queen c7 okay
huh
I wanted to play e5 at some point but
it's a bit more difficult and I don't
have that much time to think this guy is
oh this guy is on Achatz so maybe he's
done some prep
I am streaming hopefully people can see
the stream
[Music]
we just as detecting it or not
I play here
I'm just gonna play Bishop d3 develop no
reason to think for too long do I hang
up hon I hung up on but okay I won the
e6 pawn when this is the moon of Queen
take h4
so optimistic
Bishop Bishop g5 queen bee for maybe
just like Queen d2
neither for
Pleasants I'll be night off for
six let's keep developing
[Music]
uh yeah there's some strange openings
here
at age three
her Bishop f4 let's do it
strange
but I like this position not for
ft2 as i may move here first time I ever
saw that move was against year Malinsky
he absolutely crushed me yeah we have
the NACA emotes elastic hold with a
hundred bits
thanks elastic hold
a tick can castle
is everyone thinking maybe everyone was
thinking
he just hung a queen thank you
okay I still have some prep
by the way if anyone can't pick up on it
I'm really tired right now I'm
recovering from jet lag I just hang
something
I mean 95 looks so attractive
like a look at look at bites pieces
compared to plaques pieces
Bishop at four
five so this is one of the reasons I
play 9 ft 2 is so I can take with Queen
and preserve Knight c3 for later
it will here I'm just up a queen
but yeah I'm streaming because I'm
really jet-lagged and it's 7 p.m. here I
want to force myself to stay up for at
least a few more hours and if I can do
that I think it's probably the best way
to try and overcome jet lag
position confuses me rook age
looks attractive tempting to target the
queen
don't want to think for too long I could
also just take this pawn I could play e4
and do stuff the e4 attacks two pawns
oh this looks so much fun
Oh his night is tied down to the square
like before 97 is mate
ie for when your pieces are good you
should open the centre Bishop f4
interesting
56
I could play
I can play Queen d2 like Queen d2
Manas in the chats lamanna's I was
watching your stream when I woke up
today I woke up at like 4:00 a.m. London
time maybe it was 5 a.m. already forgets
I still like my position I'm just going
to castle
I'm play quick moves when I can so I'm
winning a piece here or he has to take
with King 95 is coming
um
see one I hosted your stream yeah I
forgot about that
uh it's hard to keep up with the chat so
I apologize but I'm trying my best
I'll probably read the chat after this
assignment was done I'm going to take
the pawn c5 is a good move
tic
usually when ponds are like
cash for at least one pawn also Bishop
d6 is a move but let's take cure first
simplify some stuff take that pawn
maybe I just play solid like Bishop e2
I'm in no rush to to do anything here I
could take with the pawn like Knight
here
five ideas wait a minute if I take 97 I
win this pawn my chief for out of h3 my
efore
I'll have some stuff excellent King
thanks for the one bit am I just mating
here this is beautiful
the e3
okay this is also beautiful so some
beautiful finishes this is also
beautiful from the positional standpoint
everything's so beautiful I takes you
seven
what's wrong with night
maybe I should unbend moobot unban move
odds mod moobot and then the uh time
command should work assuming moobot is
still connected to my channel did that
work
see jgp also going
move out isn't working I'm about Sproul
II uh disappointed with me by bent
abandon
it's 4131 make some sense
do I take on e4 first
the c5 is coming dick with bishop and
then play rook t1
and then
until I flag let stick here Brooke do
you 195 ideas
always play h3 always castle oh I hung
Knight b3o and he probably sees it cuz I
just told him he's probably watching too
it's unfortunate okay so I'm losing one
game he's 1602 what's his actual rating
okay he's decent player let's avoid
hanging a queen
so already one blunder but the rest of
the positions look very fine
especially this position
I do have to play faster I just read
this comment from Veronica I'm playing
so he's giving me some advice
you
what to do Bishop f1 position looks kind
of non exciting
okay this is made into
let's take in plain xe7 I think I'm
winning this pawn okay I want a game hey
I won two games four games still going X
I sparks with some emotes okay
the scheme is still really sad
I probably do have to pick up the pace
everyone's thinking which is nice
and I don't can people see the other
positions no they can't
yeah I'm just down the exchange here but
I'm gonna put up as much resistance as
possible try and create some
complications
I don't want to play f3
playable like Queenie 3d
play Queenie one I'm gonna play Queenie
one
trying to just get out of danger and
defend we can see seven should win
another pawn between c4 first and then
and eventually Queen c7
uh bits from elastic hold
a bright side about this position I have
two bishops
can't complain too much
I can't see 7up another pawn
it's really hard to play chess when
you're tired but it's really easy to
play chess when your opponent gives you
free rooks
uh let's play
do you one go for b3 do you know how to
get a feed a rating you have to play in
fee they rated tournaments you have to
like beat at least a few free they rated
players I think so it's a process
pleae five here b5 eventually f4
also tick
you safe let's be adventurous
new emotes today I've reached the limit
for emotes i made emotes of of all the
top players i could think of
not being likes [ __ ] 'land naka Apsaras
and Fabiano once I hit 50 subs will have
another emote that I can make so maybe
someday a ticked no no I want to play f4
but Queen b6 is annoying I'm probably
just worse in this position and my time
is dwindling
as f4 actually accomplished maybe f4 is
okay
defended Queen b6 is only one check
why is Shanklin 2700 he's really good at
chess
uh I don't want to move my queen so a
square can be taken
maybe Queenie five but then 25 okay also
don't want to trade Queens that's a
problem so I can play this Bishop b3 is
still on tap
you
you
okay so I have three wins three games
still going
I'm so sorry about night pots I guess I
could ban nightbot and then figure out
the issue later but maybe Nathan can
look into it as a he's the IT guy of the
stream Queen d4 looks Pleasant
d for
okay save night guys
is my pot down for everyone or is it
just me
I have a feeling it's just me
d for
or that hangs a rug
so generous
so I have faith in humanity again
now I'm just up a piece
so I'm up I'm up stuff in every game now
now it's just a matter of converting
except this game okay this is a toughest
game Brooke c4 is coming this pawn might
be weak I could play b4 but that seems
weakening
maybe I move the nights
unleashing the bishop like 9f2 looks
like a weird move but I want to maintain
my queen okay let's trade more
so I have three games going I'm
completely winning in two of them
let's kill this guy quickly rook c7
coming
but should take you for Roxy southern
Brook g8 Bishop b3
to play g3 he also wants to point out of
five
play Bishop t3
to resemble some French structure where
the bishop likes to be on d3
and he can force a queen trade with
Queen c5 I don't know what to do
I have a minute left he's playing really
quick I could retreat the Queen d2 9f5
I think looks attractive
you
weenie seven
okay I'm just gonna play Bishop t3
hopefully he'll think
let's do this
oh I forgot about the chat
yeah I'll look at the chat later I'll
ask you this I know I'll cool off mmm
move out is working
for I guess move outs doing something I
don't know how that happened but it's
good to see
so someone resigned I have four wins
only two games left this game should be
over even though I was losing just a few
moves ago this is just about me
to play Queen at 6:00 but then I played
Bishop e5 metaphoric GA Bishop III so I
don't think you can defend too much
the p3b
you
why it's fun to have so many more pieces
it's just more stuff to attack with
you
okay so rook c6
I don't understand what he wants to do
seems like a weird move he probably
wants to flag me
clicking h1
f-five is a candidate move
maybe I'll bring my knight to e3 let's
start with Knight g4
just 93 just a better square for the
night
you
ah wait a minute
what is he planning I thought he had
some Roxy for ID yep a 93
ensures he can't play rook c4
and there's increments like every move I
make I got 15 more seconds so I'm not
going to flag
okay now he wants to trade queens I'll
be a decent idea
can take and plate rook d2
you
and we have some positional game
so the other game finish okay the other
game the guy resigns so this is this is
the last game I could put all my focus
on this game or I could put most of my
focus on the chat and some of my focus
on this game when he's thinking I'll
scroll up I miss anything
- is gonna be off and on okay let's
focus on the game I have a minute left I
think I have to take can take on g6
first probably not necessary let's take
and here's more center pons than I do
zero Center pawns but the e-files
half-open I would like to play rook e1
but a for could hang maybe i play a five
that's overextending because rook c6 and
rook c5 is an idea
let's move
interesting
five tick
the defy would hang in the end
let's do it yeah because this structure
is very delicate all it takes is one
pawn break to break down some pawn
structure
you
I think he's losing oh he wants to play
night of three let's not get forked
it's rook f1 I'm losing the a pawn but
I'll win some center pawn
I could play King problem with Kim G 2
is this move
King F - that looks wrong so I'll do
this
this is actually going to turn into a
pretty sharp game
so it's all about staying calm and
drinking tea
also not flagging I have some fear of
someday this and some stuff will
eventually happen
hopefully it doesn't happen
but it's kind of scary
since he still has issues like he still
has this upon tension thing to worry
about
but there's some calculate oh I forgot
the spawn is hanging too
that's embarrassing maybe I just play
rook d2
to probably rip due to
you
so I'm telling upon and I'm down on time
but I have hope
okay so he wants to he's not holding on
to the pond he like didn't take on d5
you
we're gonna have some bishop night and
game - Rick's on the board my pawn
structure will be slightly better his F
on is gonna be a long-term weakness
I'm fantasizing about this and this and
this
someday
and
Sturgill hello and just call you master
girl so much easier to pronounce
you
if he ever does this I'll probably do
this
and here's this
so this is
tick tick
tick tick in g7 he's probably
the better there is my night is attacked
this
of annoying
what else do I do I have this move to
maybe I play this and then and then he
does this hey Lucas
thanks for the bits I'm about to flag
though can't get distracted too much
I have an idea okay I mean
wait I'm gonna play rook d4
and then he's gonna think hopefully I'm
gonna think
some tactical idea
not sure if it works other work
not gonna lie my father's pretty dope
yeah maybe we'll use a moobot then if
it's more dope than nightbot can I take
care that was my main idea I think it
works I don't really have too much time
to calculate I have this interim
insurance cover check
you
it's probably still a bit complicated
um really move the night
not too many options I
rack of tuna into the fend it's nice
still have to be careful like all these
pawns are weak am i dropping frames
again I'm sorry if I'm dropping frames
blame it on my friends internets
you
okay well he that's a nice outpost
now I don't think I'm dropping frames
it's back to green that's nice
make a one-person cyma what does that
even mean just play regular chess okay I
could have Burke f7 here
it's a beautiful combo his King is
forced
d six that would have been mate so I'm
gonna play this
I'm getting challenges from people oh I
couldn't post a viewer of viewer
tournaments
did the stream die I'm sorry if the
stream died it's not my fault also it
was my pond dying
take on each five
rook h8 is a forcing move
you
you
this is so complicated because if he's
gonna win be tuned and have two
connected passers and I have to be very
careful
I've worked you seven here really no
time to think though when you have no
time to think the best strategy is to
repeat
why is he thinking is one move
I could take or I can repeat further
you
I see some idea
which I didn't see before I have this 97
move if he plays King yet
maybe he'll think here
I'm up upon the idea of 97 is if he
takes I have 906
I'll play is something like rook before
oh no then still Knight f6
so as to keep the rook on the this rank
plays like rook c6 but I can take on h5
I think
this is okay it's a weird idea
but sometimes you got to do what you got
to do
I do apologize as the stream is sort of
dying sort of not Eve renting's for the
follow
don't drink tea it makes frames drop
I don't know maybe my computer is
jet-lagged - and that's why it's lagging
so I'm really jet-lagged it's and
there's so much red uh I don't know what
to do to fix it
I could lower the bitrate even more hey
master Gill thanks for subbing
oh it's gifted by Nathan Nathan always
pulling through with the gifts
what do I do here
getting stuff
to flag and
this
I still just want to take on each five
hey hello Laurie O'Reilly and hello to
the ice
what does 9f mean I keep hearing this
word oo f some kind of interjection
expression type word
I'm playing with increment because it's
a Sai mole I don't know if people see
this no they can't see it if I if i zoom
in this is this is my Simas core I need
one more win or a perfect Simon
and this is a London Simone because I'm
in London and I attempted to play the
London every game I didn't quite succeed
because some people played c5 on move on
but you know if I can win this game
hopefully we can inspire more people to
play the London
oof is a sound of exhaling
Oh
yes you exhale when you say roof
also inhale when you say hoof I guess no
you have to you can't inhale and say the
F sound can you
maybe you couldn't
it's difficult I'm not good with mystics
oh and he's trapping my night
caught up in these sounds
my rook is stuck this is so bad and I'm
about to flag
that's so unfortunate I'm gonna lose
this game unless I win or I draw
he's thinking to take the night did I do
wrong I just missed the show g8 strong
move
g.o his threats
I'll play rook
I'm doing
they're too
but I have two passers
an endgame
it's counterplay
g4
intending to restrict the bishop I guess
he could bail out with a draw if he
wants to take on g4 but now he can't
you
do this in this
someday this
we still have the pushing baby commands
we do
you
you just want to do this in this it's
not that easy to stop
you
Nathan if you're still watching
I saw your comment so the stream just
died again
oh I saw Nathan's comment on I want some
random YouTube video if I could do some
series or some video of how to come back
from bad positions so hopefully this
will be a kind of a mini lesson how to
come back from a bad position it's just
a matter of pushing pawns
I'm gonna keep pushing because why not
it's one of problem is he's gonna be
fast with his puns so I have to be
faster with my pawns maybe h6
I don't know chess is complicated
in g6
this is okay
if it's not okay it's my only hope so
what to do
hang-up
you
I do have an idea if you plays this
maybe I can do this
ah then he plays a 3 B 3
unfortunates
well this is a this is a definition of
the race these pawns against these pawns
he has a bishop but I have a king on g5
and this is a pretty big threat I think
so it comes with temper on the rook
time is very important in these race
positions one tempo could mean
everything
but I'm scared now she played a three
please don't beat me
you
I have no idea what's going on here this
is really complicated b3 is a good move
but what do i do do i play h6 first
you probably get away with h6 first
Bishop d3 g7
or not
- I do here
this
that's probably a terrible move
let's do this first
that was probably equally as terrible
okay I'm still going to fight
this is looking really bad this is
bishops going to be so strong
wait a minute
g7
I still have no idea what's going on
this is so complicated I have no energy
to calculate that's okay
there there take take there
you
you
you
this is looking really bad
this
it's a weird position after sack
it's a stream dying I'm sorry if the
stream is dying
what is going on
good move
this could be a draw actually
you
like things could liquidate really
quickly
I'm not going to say anything
I don't know what to say
yeah this looks like it's going to be a
draw Nadia's winning at some points but
can i play for a win
this is gonna be a draw Dillon jss
thanks for the sub
you
any any tricks to win
I don't see any tricks
we'll clear that
just in case you loses connection
okay it's a draw and it wasn't rated so
my rating doesn't die it was interesting
I guess back to Simon
Oh moe
perfect but not perfect let's look at
that endgame
because it was interesting 100 bits if I
win if I'm oh if only I knew before
go back or blackhead pawns on a 5 and B
5 and why not b 3o b 3 for me okay so I
was better around here and then things
got weird because he played Brooke b6
which is a very strong move and I went
for 97 which probably is not the best
move is this this maneuver Brooke g6 and
Bishop g8 is very strong
have to play this I plead King f2 when
you play Bishop g8 so maybe I have to
sack the pawn I was looking at this line
take h5
Brook tick
g3 King here
something like this wasn't sure was
going on but it seemed like black has
enough to at least draw if not be better
like a move move like bishop at 3:00 the
spawns hanging the Knights hanging the
rooks hanging by a Belgium novice I will
have fun in London I will also have fun
with the London
I'm only in London for another like
20 hours and then I leave for uh I leave
for Romania so it's gonna be a
short-lived short-lived London
experience uh oh thanks master gill for
the comments yeah that end game with you
it's it's been doing well maybe I should
upload more videos where I just
embarrassed myself yes I signed Nathan s
board at Chicago open it's gonna be
worth a lot of money since Sunday all
the chests streamers signed it I think
people are challenging me but I wanted
to analyze this a little bit King F to
plunder
I worked a gauge 5 is the best move okay
yeah because I miss Bishop g8 and then
somehow I got counterplay so someone was
asking what if I played b3 in what
position probably in this position b3
it's a move I didn't consider maybe it's
playable because take take I think
I don't know
tick because if take tick a four I'm
happy to put my work on 85 well black
could probably just play Bishop T 3
but maybe it's smarter to try and slow
down the pawns but maybe he still has
the same idea of this sort of a for and
then getting the past beep on so I'm not
sure how much of a difference it would
make
it's all about the title of videos yeah
I've realized that sometimes the case so
yeah it could be a very bad video with a
good title and I guess it still performs
well how is London you're living in
London London's good I took a very long
walk and a long run um for most of the
day actually I've I walked like a half
marathon today
is to prove it
in minutes
this can people see this it's how many
miles I traveled today on foot I'm about
to break 30,000 steps so probably go for
dinner later
we're like casino poker or whatever so
I'm gonna break 30,000 a a 3 B 3 I got
from you got from me
I should I should have known he was
watching and I should not have said
anything oh okay I only ran for like
through two and a half to three miles
walked most of the day but
anyway stockfish is pointing out all the
blunder is disabled let's see if I can
find the wing like I thought he was
completely winning if he just plays like
Bishop t3i they didn't have to see how
to stop this I didn't see how to make
progress either on this side
I think I was gonna play King f6e 3 and
then king f7 maybe I survived
but he probably has something like this
here it's a weird position but he can
Queen here after take tick I can't Queen
because Bishop a2 so I could play no
this is completely winning for buck
because he puts a bishop here I'll scoop
up all my pawns
so this is probably decent enough for
buck what does doctors say
yeah rook b8 is clearly just wasting
time
people yeah so but
you threw the only winning move
- first but be to rugby one and then
rugby eight okay and Bishop d3 ideas
okay so that was one when Bishop t3 is
just easier but then after rook b8 just
to draw and I didn't have open I don't
think this is all just
yeah
if anything maybe black and try and play
for a win because I can't sack the rook
for the pawn
like if you're playing black here you
should uh okay of course it's probably
gonna be a draw but you should take the
pawn and then try and get King c2 and
Bishop h5 to d1 would be the sort of
winning idea probably it's not enough
time for my King to come back but at
least it's a try
uh Manas is leaving your online after an
hour I will be back I will not be flying
in an hour
I don't know if I'm gonna be online in
like 10 minutes but we'll see
oops that's not my ID behind the phone
behind the phone
no this is this is my some random thing
I got with my sim card
I think it has my phone number but I
don't think people can see my phone
number I didn't know what the phone
number is so okay
um anything else I missed a lot of
comments from earlier O'Reilly freaking
out
um is the stream still watchable because
it's lagging and I don't know what's
going on but
I think it's watchable
villager is not my identity 'if so
that's probably a good thing
um even though he's managing my discord
channel I can play someone I can play
I don't think I've what is this is this
horde Oh nuts crazy house
uh let's play this guy
oh this is rated so I have to be
somewhat serious I'll play a London
today is a London type of day I mean c7
was a bad move
in what game
in c7
you
Oh in our game
you
so when did we trade Queens
yeah I can look later I think this guy
has messaged me in the past like just
asking for a game I get so many messages
from people asking if they can play me
and on one hand I feel flattered that
people want to like contact me directly
but it's hard to respond to everyone and
I've I get flooded with messages like
every day and especially when I'm
travelling this is just a warning that I
might overlook messages alright
sometimes it just takes too much energy
especially with the tournaments so the
best chance to play me I tell this
everyone the best chance to play me is
when I'm streaming and if you want to
know what I'm streaming just follow me
and turn on notifications I think that's
the best way
oh and Nathan working on the extension
that would be cool if some kind of AI to
respond to people would be awesome I'm
also probably just hire like a virtual
assistant be a nice idea well this is
this pawn structure what is he doing so
many weaknesses everywhere
put the knight here because these
squares are both so much you see for the
Knights
you
and blacks not developed so it's just a
matter of developing quickly
Ches I think Gotham Ches got the i''m
title or he's an I am elect now he just
needs to get the title approved at the
next Congress whenever that is
does anyone have a virtual assistant
that would like know anything about
hiring of virtual assistants or does
anyone want to be my virtual assistant
maybe I'll just put out like a job
application oh that would be cool
requirements you have to
able to write in English give you know
some chess
be polite
um 95 usually the typical move
my opponent is sort of low rated but
he's no he's light blue penguin be
related to tatev
pending the night
I'll play Queen f3
ever plays this move
actually probably be a good move
wanted to play like queen r3 queen g3
attack this pawn
you
Nathan will be my virtual assistant
actually probably be a very good Virtual
Assistants I would have to I would have
to advance Li work out what I need help
for and what what specific jobs I can
outsource I would either pay like an
hourly fee like for hourly work or like
a weekly contract or something I don't
know I've never hired anyone so
it would be
would be new
would probably be worth it
10 cents per message actually really
that's really good deal
take my rating I'm probably get me
banned for account sharing
[Music]
so free pawn
exercise sparks helping to offer or
offering to help
it's hard to say words being so tired
Tushar is willing to do it
help my students
yeah I just want to like I always had
this idea of connecting students for
like for training games and then offer
check like go over games with students
who play each other and vehicle concepts
you
you
like I have a lot of bad
I have a lot of chess ideas which are
[Music]
very executable just I I would need some
supports like very simple kind of
project ideas so I think after after I
finish these two tournaments all along
I'll probably reach out to people who
are offering
you
I have mod Z I have mods in the chat I
don't know why these are
getting weird messages recently
yeah I'm gonna make a list I'm gonna
make a list of requirements are like
what exactly
I'll need from people and while I can
pay and that would be cool
and some of the things are just like
entrepreneurial like endeavors like some
chess website projects so I own a lot of
web like website
it just domains
[Music]
i'ma let go in Chiapas rook
maybe even trap his queen somehow
I just want to do this I probably won't
even take his rook uh well he's getting
some counterplay
let's take this
yeah I probably won't take his work I'm
just gonna leave my bishops here and
watch him suffer
this is so nice like the rook can't move
Knight is pinned
stuck for the most parts
annika is in dire need for a job okay
I will have to think
you
okay he makes a move so do I take the
rook
for torture they go for torture in the
pond maybe I'll take care and when all
those kingside ponds and then in the
very end play rook age 3 and rook rook
g3 and somehow mates
oh by the way this is probably going to
be my last game I see I have eight
pending challenges maybe I'll accept
someone pick one last person I don't
know I'm not gonna look at the
challenges until after this game
finishes let's just take care looks so
much fun
take G 6.86 King h8 Queen jh5 King moves
back to the G file somewhere and rook h3
you
that's I could pretty much
and this is a mate threat you can't
really stop it
nice
you
where would assist in jobless
B when it comes out I would post on
discord and on Twitter
and maybe on my website
Court in Twitter I think are the easiest
communication platforms jump in Jackson
thanks for the follow you appreciate
that okay a lot of people are
challenging me do I know any of these
people master Gil I'll play master Gil
because he's a newest sub gifted by
Nathan
you
okay master Gill are you alive are you
online
you
another message
someone who's never played an iron and
wants to play me
yeah I'm just tired so this might be the
last game
oh it says there his ratings
I want to do something new against this
opening can I do that's new
not too many
like crazy options I could play from
early on
I'll start with my c6 it's the most
flexible move
okay so he's going for a close Sicilian
I'll play this idea that I played the
other day
it's starting with e 6 and then
recreates some idea that calm Sookie
played the early plan of B 5 B 4
you
you
on the kid is also gifted by Nathan yeah
I think most a lot of the subs are
gifted by Nathan Nathan's just a super
sub
you
I could read messages on stream but I
would feel wrong about doing that
because I guess I've done it maybe a few
times before
but if they're like private messages I
usually try to avoid it
um this this 93 move is actually useful
for lights in many cases
you
I don't know what to do I'm gonna play
Queen b6
- just discourage f4 he plays that for
anyway
got guts
yippy Knight g4 could be annoying for
him
I wanted to play c4 but then d4
doesn't really lead to much
before deep or
does look interesting though I'm gonna
do it
position you play is king each one
instantly let's trade and then I'll go
for an IG for
one of the main plans is to bring the
bishop to Asics like if he plays G for
Bishop Asics could be a bit problematic
for whites
you
speak pipe app
that would be really cool allowing
people to submit voice questions but
would people actually do that
that'd be interesting
you
someday
exploit these squares
problem is he has f2 covered by this
night so maybe I'll play like H 5 H 4
open H file great some pin and then
someday play 9 f 2
d for I think that oh I take D for lose
a piece
hmm
it's a good move
so that you seven
well this is casual so even if I lose
one effects
we'll have too much emotional effects
I'm gonna take this pond
I still want to play Bishop a6 I still
want to play h5
just a matter he's probably gonna do
something in the time that he has
jay-j chess has joined the chat while i
was gonna add in a stream really soon
but now that JJ is here
I might have to continue until he leaves
JJ you're in Turkey right
wait turkey turkey right I was in Turkey
like last year for one day
there's a nice country really nice hotel
but I really didn't see much of Turkey
just like the airports
want to want to play Queen g1 and
smothered mate him it's gonna take
several more steps
you play h5
like Bishop I don't know I'm soaking
I mean the start with Bishop Asics is
it's a nice starting with developing
Ankara
never heard of Ankara I've only heard of
Istanbul and Constantinople but when I
entered Turkey last year I got to the
airport and didn't realize I needed a
visa to get into the country
I had like a connecting flight the next
day luckily you can just buy a visa at
the reports there was no problem
so that worked out well
wait a minute
he's getting initiative I don't really
want to play f6 I could castle
let's castle king safety first I lose a
pawn if he takes on f7 I probably just
play Kimia chase
I'm more concerned about peace activity
someday very soon I'll play rugby it's
yeah US passport is very strong I will I
will agree with that
where does I am rose and have the most
followers what does that mean like at
which social media platform
I think I know the answer to that
my works here I'm probably just worse
but he's 1443
take the pond
I could mmm I'm doing I'll stick the
fine
working on your Nike nightbot commands
and updating your twitch profile I need
to work on my nightbot commands too
actually I probably just need to work on
nightbot because it's not working
Queen age 5 is terrifying because he
wants to do this and this maybe these
ideas
I don't know what to do also f1 is
hanging I kind of forgot about iPad G no
g6 is terrible
play this move defends everything
this is coming I don't think I have time
to oh my gosh I don't have any time
ah i doing
I'll do this
for the best
there's no increment either ah that was
a nice gift
I don't know why he did that he probably
just didn't see my Knights Knights can
move backwards
is he gonna see the rooking oh he
counter-attacks and he's writing meat
and I'm about to flag I have to take
you
okay 11 seconds I think I can do this I
also have to read the chat
yeah might very soon within a few weeks
I'll have the most as they don't call it
followers but I'll have the most
subscribers on YouTube because I'm
getting like 30 or 40 every every day
distraction with a hundred bits I don't
get distracted with my when it's not my
turn okay now I'm distracted and I take
this I think I can take that what was
that he's just trying to slow me down
I'll be a good strategy
you
okay I'll start playing faster once I
get the low five seconds
not get that cremated
I'm gonna just smother my King because
Ethan doesn't have any Knights
and then I'll go for the kill I'll play
like Queen d2 and then probably just
flag him he's thinking so much here
what is the smooth four seconds this is
a slowest time scramble ever
okay how this is a very slow time
scramble good game master Gil you almost
beat me you just had to move quicker and
not not care about the quality of the
moves just care about the speed of the
moves
um yeah okay so the platform where I
have the most followers is no this is
surprising or unsurprising but it's Li
Ches
I think I hit
my over 2000 no 1933 so it's actually
pretty similar between twitch and me
chess I guess so many people want to
play
I are meskhi wants to play I
tamo Lear is here yeah I'm in London can
people see out the window you see this
that's London
hope you guys enjoyed that
you
I was in a stream from like a more
public place but it was difficult Wi-Fi
anyway
what to do
I don't know I might just end it
look at Queen c7 move okay
didn't take too much energy you think
playing the London is mandatory
the stream title refers to the city and
not the opening but I guess the opening
is
I wouldn't call it mandatory but it's
it's a good opening it's one of the best
openings what do I want to do I wanted
to look at Queen c7 because I'm already
forgetting the game
- sharp
yeah I forget when did we trade Queens
Queen c7 so early
ah Queen c7 here so this is yeah this is
a new move it made me think because I've
played so many people that play
at least in bullets a lot of people take
on c5 and I play e5 and it's it's a
great position and then there's other
group of people who take and then I play
ninety four and then they move the
bishop back and I play Knight d6 I've
had this a number of times too
so for future reference the best way to
play this for black is to take on on c5
she didn't do and then after ninety four
best move is not to move the bishop but
to play Knight of six taking advantage
of the tactic after Knight takes e5 when
85 check
I mean take c5 black is at least equal
here it's pleasant position to Center
pawns White has two bishops so I guess
it's have been imbalanced but for black
players who play c5 against e4 this is
just something to know so um Queen C oh
my gosh my mouse died
Queen c7
I wanted to check opening book
black score as well Wow how popular is
Queen c7
see %
should I play b4 where I can play Knight
b5 here
ninety-five win takes e5
Bishop III initiative this is probably
some computer prep so I'll turn on the
computer
at Bishop III I guess I didn't go for
this because this looks scary
but c7 is a constant worry you can't
take you take on b2
ninety-seven
you
now this is fine for whites so queen a5
yeah this has got to be good for whites
because I'm I just just develop
ship f4 okay threatening this basics is
basically forced
if five can keep the initiative I like
the sign in 59550 too
for whites us too
go get something to eat stay alive
deadlock with the is that Turkish I
think that's Turkish
here to translate this something about
YouTube video and me
and something about the chat and asana
the rest I can't really decipher
Nathan with soccer emotes or football
emotes because I'm I'm in Europe now
after being crushed by me Minh Truong is
inspired to play the London system
that's exciting
London system is easy to learn it's just
a matter of starting
yeah so anyway I learned something new
on this Queen c7 move can be met with
Knight b5 it's good to know
so I'm probably gonna take off I know
there's people messaging me and
challenging me all want to play I don't
know when my next stream is gonna be cuz
oh let me turn on stockfish slows down
the computer I fly to Romania tomorrow
there's a chance that I'll stream from
the airport as I have lounge access oh
no what is going on I have lounge access
with like Wi-Fi like free Wi-Fi at the
airport hopefully it's fast enough so I
might stream then if I don't stream then
I'll try and stream in Romania at some
point I'll be playing a tournament and
I'll be with another streamer ah who
maybe will do some like some dual
streams or whatever I don't know all
depends on Wi-Fi
anyway I'm gonna take off I might raid
someone
anyone streaming that's notable I'm the
only person streaming who else is
streaming chess
you
okay I might stream someone or I like to
raid someone after the stream ends uh
Nathan asking which streamer what's his
name Costa both Iacobucci
I think that's I mentioned that before
usually streams for Chester University
but he also has his own channel so hate
I'll with the 50 bits Thank You tile for
anyone else who I didn't think for
following or doing whatever thanks for
being so supportive it does help
so I'm I'm appreciative Thank You 0-0
mattei most recent follow yeah I mean I
end it here
get some sleep maybe get some food drink
some more tea and I'll see you guys in
the future